Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich nicht ein Problem mit dezentralen sozialen Netzwerken. Das ist ja tatsächlich einfach ein Datenschutzeinstellungsproblem. Also selbst ein zentrales Netzwerk wie Facebook würde ja auch sagen, genau das nicht leisten, wenn nur einfach die Datenschutzeinstellungen restriktiver werden.
Völlig richtig. Aber Facebook hat das ja am Anfang auch eben nicht gemacht. Diese Funktionen, diese datenschutzrelevanten Funktionen sind ja erst später hinzugekommen. Also am Anfang war das deutlich öffentlicher. Auch das Bewusstsein. Es ist ja ein gesellschaftliches Problem. Wenn wir darüber reden, wie schaffen wir es, ein dezentrales Netzwerk zum Erfolg zu verhelfen? Wie schaffen wir es, das zu etablieren? Dann müssen wir uns auch fragen, wie kriegen wir es tatsächlich raus? Und es reicht eben nicht, dass jeder das auf seinem Computer in der Küche laufen ist.
Na klar, aber bei Diaspora war jetzt die Standardeinstellung nicht, dass ich sehen konnte, wer alles deine Freunde sind. Wäre jetzt diese Standardeinstellung so gewesen, dass das der Fall wäre, dann hätte es diesen Effekt eher gegeben. Das ist jetzt eine Abwägung, wo man sagt, das war jetzt deswegen nicht so erfolgreich und so losgegangen womöglich. Aber auch gleichzeitig hat es diese Daten eben nicht preisgegeben, was ja auch ein schöner Vorteil ist. Und das ist halt eine Sache, die man abwägen muss. Aber wir hatten vorher E-Mail, wir haben jetzt alle da Facebook oder doch ein großer Teil. Und wenn es jetzt sozusagen eine wirklich gute Empfehlung gibt, wie Diaspora, dann wird sich das auch irgendwie rumsprechen. Man wird irgendwie, also ich hab in meinem Facebook-Profil, meine letzte Erinnerung war jetzt hier, das ist übrigens meine Diaspora-Adresse. Aber ich noch auf einen ganz anderen Punkt kommen, der so ein bisschen fehlte, wo man einfach den Nutzer jetzt abholen muss, um so in diese Richtung auch zu kommen. Und das ist eben das, was Jan auch mit Login meinte. Man baut geschlossene Systeme, wenn man Leute über diese bequemen Sachen erreichen will, dann müssen sie alle Teil dieses Systems werden. Aber das ist ja eben der Punkt, der mich davon auch abhält, Leute in anderen Systemen wie MySpace, Twitter oder so eine Nachricht zu schicken. Da gibt es dann schon erste API-Elemente, die sozusagen bilateral zwischen den beiden Services eine Anbindung erlauben, häufig. Aber eben genau das ist das, was eben gepusht werden muss und das, was letztlich so ein protokollgetriebenes, dezentrales Netzwerk liefern würde. Dass es eben größere Netzwerkaggregate gibt. Wir haben ja, wie gesagt, gmx oder web.de, ein deutschsprachiger Netzwerk, der E-Mail-Anbieter und genauso gibt es natürlich dann weiterhin ein Facebook, wo Leute hinrennen und dann eben Teil von einem wirklichen sozialen Netzwerk sind, was auch dem Netzwerk folgt. Und nicht, das war ja immer so das Bild, wir haben ein Netzwerk, das ist jetzt bei einem Anbieter und ist von der Struktur her gar nicht sozusagen dem technisch, dem sozialen Netzwerk nachempfunden.
Aber das, was Jenga gesagt hat, sind ja eigentlich zwei total wichtige Fragen in dem ganzen Komplex. Die eine Frage ist ja die, und so versuche ich Technik immer ein bisschen zu verstehen, dass ich mir angucke, was für gesellschaftliche Mechanismen stecken da eigentlich dahinter? Was muss das abbilden? Und wo geht es vielleicht sogar darüber hinaus? Entwickelt neue Kulturen? In dem Fall geht es darum, unser Gesellschaftsverhalten abzubilden, unsere Interaktion. Und wenn ich mich in einem bestimmten Umfeld bewege, wenn ich mich aufhalte mit drei Kumpels, dann verhalte ich mich anders, als wenn ich irgendwo auf der Bühne stehe. Das ist ja völlig klar. Und dieses Feeling dafür, ob wir gerade auf der Bühne stehen im Netz oder ob wir gerade mit drei Kumpels reden, das muss sich halt auch in der Software widerspiegeln. Und im Moment geht das manchmal ganz schön drastisch schief. Und das wird sich langsam entwickeln. Und dabei gibt es auch richtig interessante kulturelle Veränderungen. Und eine kann sein, dass man viel offener wird, dass man viel mehr rausbläst. Im negativen Sinn gesprochen, oder dass man einfach toleranter wird im Umgang. Und ich glaube, beides findet statt. Ich glaube, dass es nicht so einfach geht, wie viele das sagen im Sinne von der transparenten Gesellschaft. Und jetzt ist alles von uns immer total transparent. Sondern wir differenzieren natürlich nach unseren Adressatenkreisen. Und das werden wir immer tun. Und die Frage ist, wie kriegen wir es jetzt hin, das so zu strukturieren, dass quasi die technischen Systeme und wir in der Form interagieren, wo beiden Seiten klar ist, was wir eigentlich wollen.
Es gibt ja ein Dezentrale Soziales Netzwerk, was sich auch etabliert hat in den letzten zehn Jahren. Das ist ein Chatprotokoll namens Jabba. Da steht es sozusagen alternativ zu so was wie ICQ oder MSN. Hat mal so seine Seitenleiste mit ganz vielen Benutzern. Und da kann man sich auch aussuchen, nicht nur welchen Kleint man benutzt, sondern auch an welchen Server man sich seinen Account holt. Ein Teil seiner Adresse wird dieser Servername. Und da hast du, Markus, auf der Herfahrt gesagt, wir sind ja alle bei den CCC-Servern. Es ist ja auch interessant, dass dann sozusagen an so einem Punkt viele Leute ein Vertrauen in die bösen Hacker stellen. Weil wir halt an der Stelle dann doch eher den Datentrots natürlich auch bieten wollen. Und es sind halt auch bei uns, also ich bin nicht vom CCC, sondern beim Berliner CCC hab ich meinen Account. Und so hab ich ja auch wieder so einen kleinen soziotopischen Raum. Und ich wette, in Frankreich sind das irgendwie andere Server, die benutzt werden und die sind nicht so stark auf dem CCC. Und so gibt's auch, wenn auch kleine andere Gruppen in deutschsprachigem Bereich, die anderes nutzen. Das macht ja auch Sinn. Ich hab natürlich mit Leuten aus Berlin, aus dem Chaos Computer Club, mehr Kontakt und mehr Nachrichten. Deswegen macht es ja auch sozusagen fast schon ökologisch, ökonomisch Sinn, die Nachrichten auch über einen Server in Berlin zu belassen. Und dann gibt es natürlich zwischen dem Berliner CCC Server wahrscheinlich viel Traffic mit dem Bundes CCC Server, weil Hacker untereinander auch wahrscheinlich bundesweit viel quatschen werden.
Was? Sie reden miteinander?
Und so folgt dann sozusagen auch dieses Entstehen von Servern und Nutzen von Servern den sozialen Kreisen.
Aber das ist ja sozusagen, das ist ja direkt ein Schritt weg von dieser jeder hat sein eigenes Ding in der Küche. Das würde ich ja gerade sagen.
Das wäre jetzt diese vielen zentralen Punkte. Und klar, man muss das weiter und feiner aufliegen, man darf sich damit nicht zufriedengeben. Also 8.000 Leute ist schon viel zu viel. Ab 10.000 muss man Vorreste anspeichern.
Und das ist ja genau, der Job ist ja so ein Ding, das gibt es schon wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich lange. Aber da hat das bei dieser irgendwie, wir stecken, wir tun uns was in einen kleinen Stecker, so in eine Steckdose und dann läuft es, hat auch noch nicht funktioniert. Woran liegt das da? Und vor allen Dingen, wenn das da schon nicht klappt, bei so einem jahrealten Protokoll, wie soll das dann bei so einem komplexen Ding wie einem sozialen Netzwerk funktionieren? Wer soll das denn machen?
Ich glaube, die Sache ist einfach, dass es aus dem Auge gelassen wurde und so ein bisschen wie dieses, warum verschicken wir nicht verschlüsselt E-Mails, weil es ein bisschen kompliziert ist. Und alles ging halt alles, eine Entwicklung lange Zeit zu anderen Formen von, wie Webseiten funktionieren. Und auch solche Unarten, wie dass man E-Mails in einem Webbrowser liest. Und wir haben da viel versäumt, was man eigentlich gerade biegen muss. Und die Frage ist, ob es zu spät ist. Und ich glaube, das glaube ich nie.
Das ist so ein bisschen eine Frage der Marktmodelle, was setzt sich durch und was für Angebote sind. Und da sind ein paar kritische Faktoren, die ändern sich gerade. Erstens, Software wird viel daukompatibler. Man will es nicht glauben.
Das stimmt, das sieht man an Facebook zum Beispiel sehr.
Aber es gibt viel mehr Leute, die Computer benutzen, wo man sagen würde, das hätten die vor 20 Jahren nicht gemacht. Das liegt nicht daran, dass die so viel computeraffiner geworden sind, sondern dass einfach viel mehr Produkte da sind, die die auch benutzen können. Und so ist das denkbar, dass das auch für einen einfachen Server, für ein dezentrales soziales Netzwerk geht. Das ist ein. Und das andere ist, die Hardwarekosten gehen. Und das, was dafür nötig ist an Hardware, das passt zusammen. Wenn du sagst, so ein Server kostet nur noch 25 Euro oder 17 Euro oder sowas, und da ist die Software gleich mit drauf und den steckst du in die Steckdose. Nicht mehr 1000 Euro oder 5000 Euro, dann ist das irgendwie ein anderes Angebot.
Aber wann ist es denn so weit, dass es wirklich klappt? Das ist ja die Frage. Wann gibt's denn zum Beispiel, warum bastelt es niemand mal so einen Jabber-Server in diesem Steckdosen-Computer? Das müsste doch einfach so ein komisches dezentrales Netzwerk. Hier, wetterfrosch. Technischer Kompetenzberg, ganz oben.
Also ein Problem, das wir immer noch haben, ist, dass wir kein richtiges Internet zu Hause haben. Also feste IP-Adressen wären schon sehr praktisch, aber na klar, man kann auch da Lösungen finden, die mit den dynamischen Adressen, die sie vergeben werden, klarkommen. Es ist eine Sache von, müsste man einfach mal machen.
Aber das wird ja jetzt mit der IPv6-Umstellung alles viel besser.
Oh ja.
Das ist sozusagen das Highland der Technik. Die Frage ist ja auch, also Jabber zum Beispiel funktioniert ja auch intern bei Firmen. Es sind ja sozusagen Firmenetze, die einen eigenen E-Mail-Server haben, die auch einen eigenen Jabber-Server haben. Und da ist zum Beispiel Datenschutz ganz, ganz wichtig, weil die sagen, wenn wir irgendwas über einen externen Dienst laufen lassen, dann können wir nicht mehr garantieren, dass die Information unser Haus nicht verlässt. Und insofern, das können ja auch Einfallstore sein. War es ja auch für E-Mail. Also E-Mail haben die Leute ja zuerst auf der Arbeit verwendet und haben dann irgendwann gemerkt, hey cool, das funktioniert auch privat. Da kann ich mich auch auf ein Bier verabreden. Aber die Einführungen, auch Universitäten, sind ja dann in dem Fall Arbeitsplätze.
Und dann hat irgendjemand angefangen, PowerPoint-Präsentationen per E-Mail zu verschicken. Und das war der Anfang vom Ende.
Genau. Und wenn wir jetzt also sagen, wir nutzen oder wir vergleichen E-Mail und soziale Netzwerke, könnte man ja auch hingehen und sagen, Diaspora gehört in jedes eigentliche Unternehmensnetzwerk. Eigentlich überall, wo ein Fileserver steht, überall, wo ein E-Mail funktioniert, sollte auch ein eigener Diaspora-Note stehen, weil die Informationen, die man mit seinen Arbeitskollegen teilt, die man seinem Arbeitgeber mitteilen möchte, ist nicht zwangsläufig dieselbe Information, die man seinen Freunden mitteilen möchte.
Da bin ich jetzt aber ein bisschen überrascht, weil dann sagst du ja im Prinzip, dass man zwei soziale Netzwerkprofile in Zukunft betreiben müsste. Nämlich eins nur auf der Arbeit benutzt, dann auch auf dem Knoten auf der Arbeit ist und dann noch eins draußen. Das ist ja genau das, was man nicht will bei einem sozialen Netzwerk.
Ja, habt ihr das kürzlich in den Nachrichten? Daimler-Kollegen wurden zu ihrem Chef beordert, weil sie eine Gruppe geliked haben, wo also der Chef von Daimler irgendwie nicht so gut wegkam.
Wieso hat er ein Tequilla-Trinkspül mitgemacht?
Nee, da wurde so ein bisschen kritisiert und das haben die Leute einfach geliked. Das fanden die gut, dass der mal so sein Fett wegbekommt. Dann wurden sie eben zum Chef zitiert und ihnen wurde nochmal gezeigt, was sie eigentlich unterschrieben haben bei der Einstellung. Das war nämlich, dass man das Unternehmen natürlich auch im Privaten so nicht beleidigt und irgendwie respektvoll behandelt. Das ist sozusagen aus der Unternehmenssicht irgendwie auch klar und verständlich, aber die Frage ist eben, wie kommt es Unternehmen dazu, die privaten Nachrichten oder die privaten Aktionen von Mitarbeitern oder von Leuten zu lesen. Und das tut es nur deswegen, weil ja eben alle auf diesem Facebook sind. Und das ist ein Problem, was wir über dezentrale Netze ja durchaus lösen können.
Wobei da natürlich auch der Faktor ist, ich hab auch gerne zwei E-Mail-Adressen, weil Sachen in der Firma haben vielleicht firmengeheim relevante Inhalte, wo ich dann sag, da ist dann auch bitte der Administrator unserer Firma am Mailserver, für gerade stehen, dass diese Mails sicher liegen. Und dann möchte ich dieses Problem sozusagen nicht so fahrlässig sein, dass irgendein Anbieter in die Hand zu drücken oder das Problem Kumpel aufzubürden, dass der dann auch noch für das Geschäftsgeheimnis meiner Firma gerade stehen soll. Und insofern ist das mehrere Accounts haben durchaus mal sinnvoll. Die Frage ist, wie man das dann verknüpft und wie das sich im Verkleiden des Nutzers darstellt.
Das ist ja ein herer Ansatz, so was zu sagen. Aber ich glaube, die meisten Nutzer wollen ja genau Folgendes. Sie wollen irgendwie eigentlich einen Netzwerke-Account haben, mit dem sie auch mit den Arbeitskollegen Freunde sind, wo sie aber eigentlich die Möglichkeit haben zu sagen, folgende Information möchte ich nicht, dass sie meinen Chef zum Beispiel erreicht. Also kann man sagen, eine selber Schuld, wenn euch nicht klar ist, dass eure Facebook-Likes euren Chef bereichnen, dann hättet ihr euch mal die Datenschutzeinstellungen angucken müssen. Das ist ja, glaube ich, eher tatsächlich ein User-Problem als ein Problem eines dezentralen oder zentralen Netzwerks.
Na ja, in erster Linie ist es ein gesellschaftliches Problem. Teilweise ist es ja so, ich kenne jetzt eine Branche, die eher mit Kommunikation zu tun hat. Dort ist es so, wenn du in eine Firma reinkommst, hast du eigentlich am dritten Tag sämtliche Mitarbeiter, die du einmal auf dem Flur auf dem Kaffee gesehen hast, schon als Freunde anfragen bei Facebook. Das ist nicht schlecht, das ist gut, weil da funktioniert der ganze Flurfunk das, was normalerweise früher, als man noch geraucht hat, hat man das ja eben bei der Raucherpause noch besprochen, was jetzt sozusagen gerade anliegt oder wie man irgendwie jetzt mit dem Kunden Sachen bespricht. Das funktioniert ja so nicht mehr. Da gibt es dann im Zweifel einen Facebook-Chat.
Wir halten also fest, Nichtraucher, die keinen Facebook-Account haben, sind Raues.
Naja, es ist ja so, wir sind ja Menschen, wir sind ja adaptiv. Also wir suchen uns ja immer den Weg, der am einfachsten ist, der am wenigsten kostet, der am schnellsten funktioniert und der am schnellsten eben auch zum Ergebnis führt. Und darin sind wir extrem gut, sonst wären wir nicht so weit gekommen. Sonst würden wir jetzt nicht hier über dezentrale soziale Netzwerke sprechen.
Du meinst, wir haben eigentlich Luxusprobleme?
Wir haben absolut Luxusprobleme.
Was wir jetzt diskutieren, sind ja zum großen Teil soziale Komponenten, die ganz viel auch damit zu tun haben, dass Leute, die das Zeug benutzen, sich darüber Gedanken machen müssen. Und das ist ja glaube ich, wenn ich manche Leute betrachte, der eigentliche Fallstrick. Das ist ja sowohl bei Facebook als auch bei den dezentralen sozialen Netzwerken so. Die Leute müssen sich selber Gedanken machen, damit es so besser im Sinne eines Datenschutzideals wird. Glaubt ihr wirklich, das ist Erfolgversprechend?
Ich glaube der Trick ist, dass es implizit ist. Dass er dann, so wie Wetter gerade sagte, vielleicht anfängt es tatsächlich absichtlich auf der Arbeit, mit einer anderen E-Mail-Adresse unterwegs zu sein als privat. Das machen viele von uns sowieso. Oder sogar noch mehr E-Mail-Adressen für verschiedene Kontexte. Und in unterschiedlichen Applikationen weiß ich wieder, habe ich einen anderen Kontext. Wir erlauben zum Beispiel und empfehlen das auch allen, wir erlauben die private Nutzung von E-Mail am Arbeitsplatz. Viele Firmen machen das nicht. Aber Bedingung ist bei uns, dass für die E-Mail-Nutzung ein Web-Interface benutzt wird, sodass sich das deutlich optisch abhebt von dem internen Interface. Das ist ein einfacher Trick. Aber es passiert wahnsinnig viel seltener, dass es so eine Vermischung gibt dieser zwei Sphären, die man halt aus vielen Gründen im Moment ganz schön trennen muss und wo es aber sowieso auch sinnvoll ist sie zu trennen. Aber es ist nicht einfach.
Dann müsste man quasi ein dezentrales Firmen mit hässlichem Design und super effektiv und dann noch ein dezentrales Netzwerk in clicky-bunty machen.
Ich glaube es sind unterschiedliche Applikationen, die sozusagen die Kernapplikation des jeweiligen Netzwerks ist. Für deinen Austausch mit deiner Mama ist es vielleicht im Moment das Medium-E-Mail, weil das funktioniert und das läuft. Und für jemand anderes ist es für eine andere Peer Group ist es halt auch eine andere Applikation. Für mich ist es Twitter in einem bestimmten Kontext und auf der Arbeit wird es vielleicht ein Tool sein, wie euer Intranet. Und da habt ihr einen eigenen Java-Service, der da integriert ist.
Ich muss aber tatsächlich sagen, es gibt ganz, ganz viele Leute, die nutzen einfach Facebook. Also für alles. Da rede ich jetzt sowohl von Kollegen, als auch von Privatpersonen, die ich kenne. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das ein erfolgsversprechender Ansatz aus User Perspektive ist, dass man sagt, pass mal auf, hier ein neues System und du musst aussehen, mach zweifelchen in der Applikation. Ich glaube tatsächlich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Werden wir sehen.
Werden wir sehen. Okay. Ihr könnt auch gerne anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. Wenn ihr auch denkt, das ist doch alles Quatsch, was die da erzählen oder der eine oder der andere, könnt ihr gerne hier Bescheid sagen. Die Nummer kennt ihr ja. Jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit über die sozialen Komponenten besprochen. Das hört sich dann so ein bisschen an. Die technischen Herausforderungen sind eigentlich schon gemeistert. Ist das tatsächlich der Fall? Also es ist eigentlich nur eine Frage von, es muss jetzt mal fertig werden, dann geht es los. Oder gibt es tatsächlich noch ein paar Probleme, die da geklärt werden müssen, bevor das irgendwie funktioniert?
Ah, so. Gut, dass ich jetzt schon gefragt habe. Ja, man muss es immer nur machen. So, mein Gott, alles ist möglich. Es ist halt eine Menge Arbeit. Und wenn man es richtig machen will, muss man noch viele andere Probleme auch dabei lösen. Was weiß ich, die Verwendung der Programmiersprachen und so, da fängt es schon an. Und da ist halt wirklich auch die Frage, auf welcher Ebene wollen wir jetzt, also das sind jetzt Manöverfragen, die man eigentlich diskutieren muss, auf welcher Ebene geht es weiter sozusagen sollen? Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Also wenn ihr an dieser Diskussion Dezentrale Netzwerke noch einen ganz bestimmten Punkt geklärt haben wollt, dann ist auch jetzt ein guter Zeitpunkt nun anzurufen, weil ich kann versprechen, wir werden in 40 Minuten nicht mehr den Rest der Welt erklären. Das wird wohl nicht klappen. Und deswegen ist jetzt nochmal eine gute Idee. Mangels Hörer, sagen würde ich jetzt nicht mehr wissen, was ist denn das große technische Problem? Also zum Beispiel, was ich mir vorstelle, ist, die Kommunikation zwischen diesen einzelnen Knoten, wie wird die denn gestaltet, ist das schon klar, wie das laufen soll? Wird dann einfach Jabber benutzt? Also können diese Knoten jabbern oder was passiert da?
Also Schatz, sollten wir nochmal einen kleinen Überblick geben, auch mit der Hilfe von Jan, welche verschiedene Ansätze es noch so gibt. Letztlich sind das glaube ich bei Diaspora Web Server, die miteinander interagieren und sich Daten über Web Server, HTTP-Protokolle übergeben, die dabei verschlüsselt sind. Es gibt andere Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerksansätze, wo tatsächlich das Jabber zugrunde liegende Protokoll XMPP verwendet wird. Das geht sogar so weit, dass du mit deinem Google-Email-Account und sogar mit deinem Facebook-Account Jabber nutzen kannst. Das ist gleichzeitig im Jabber-Protokoll kannst du Leute, also ich hab jetzt hier das Jabber, das tolle alternative Ding, und Facebook hat sich sozusagen auch ein bisschen den Jabber-Server angeklebt. Das heißt, ich kann über meinen Jabber-Align mit Leuten chatten, die in der Web-Oberfläche von Facebook sind. Also bei mir hat das immer geklappt, als ich das probiert hab. Meine Facebook-Freunde sind halt so meine Hauptzielgruppe mit den Leuten, mit denen ich chatte.
Es klappt tatsächlich manchmal, aber es ist nicht so ein Ding, was man sozusagen, also wenn man sich anfängt darauf zu verlassen, funktioniert es meistens nicht. Dann sagt man so eine Sätze, aber ich war heute die ganze Zeit online. Das sind dann sozusagen Standardprogramme. Keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, ob es funktioniert. Aber trotzdem nochmal die Frage, das hätte ich technisch geklärt. Also ich sag nur eine Frage, der Programmierer eines Dezentralen Sozialen Netzwerkes entscheidet sich einfach, er macht jetzt was und damit sind alle Probleme weg.
Nee, es fehlt die Spezifikation. Man muss sich darüber einigen, was man benutzt. Zum einen muss man sich auf einem Anwendungslayer Gedanken machen. Wie sehen die Features genau aus? Welche Einstellungen sollen möglich sein? Da wird Facebook am ehesten auch das Vorbild sein, denke ich mal. Weil Facebook, die machen sowas in der Perfektion, mit dem Funktionalitätenumfang als erste, als Pioniere, das heißt, das ist so ein bisschen die Blaupause, oder als erfolgreichste derzeit. Ich mein, Myspace war sicher auch vorher da, Twitter ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen eine andere Anwendung. Aktuell ist es halt Facebook, deswegen klar, das wird dann irgendwie ein bisschen die Blaupause sein, von dem wie es von der Anwendung her funktioniert. Und da muss man sich ja technisch überlegen und fix machen. Das sind halt auch Glaubenskriege, die zwischen Technikern ausgeführt werden, jetzt welches Software die bessere ist und welche Programmiersprache man daneben muss. Und gerade wenn wir jetzt mit so heeren Ansprüchen rangehen, dass das auf kleinen Computern effizient laufen soll, auf 100 Dollar Laptops in der dritten Welt, dann muss man sich da ordentlich, ausgiebig Gedanken machen und eigentlich auch Kohle reinstecken, eine Menge. Und dann sind irgendwie die 200.000 auch schnell weg, die sie erst Berührungs hatten.
Da sind aber auch viele Leute mittlerweile dran, ne? Also das W3C, die haben ja den Standard hinter...
Genau, die Internet-Standard-Organisation, oder zumindest was das WWW anbelangt.
Alle, die sind irgendwie, würde ich sagen, neben der ITF. Aber es gibt auch noch eine ganze Reihe von weiteren. Die machen dazu seit zwei, drei Jahren schon intensive Arbeitsgruppenarbeit. Und machen dazu Konferenzen. Eine findet in Berlin demnächst statt und diskutieren das weit über Diaspora hinaus.
Dass Diaspora jetzt gerade zu sagen, der erste Schuss, der am erfolgreichsten war. status.net, kannst du das nochmal kurz erklären, wie das funktioniert?
Das ist im Prinzip aber ein sehr ähnlicher Ansatz, der auch nur Statusmeldungen versucht auszutauschen. Es gibt eine ganze Reihe, die darunter liegenden Protokolle sind nicht so wahnsinnig unterschiedlich. Es ist aber doch eine ganze Bandbreite, die ineinander verzahnt werden. Web-ID, teilweise kommt OpenID und OAuth als Mechanismen zum Einsatz in dem ganzen Setup der Architekturen, die da zusammenspielen. Aber es kommt halt auch sehr drauf an, was man eigentlich für einen Teil von sozialen Netzwerkfunktionalitäten abbilden will.
Und noch viel mehr. Letztlich ist auch eine Frage, wie man die Sache benutzt, die man hat. Ich meine, ich kann euch alle einladen zu einer Party über ein Facebook-Event. Ich kann euch auch eine E-Mail schreiben. Ich kann auch an diese E-Mail eine Veranstaltungsdatei, das gibt es auch, so ein Kalenderstandard, dass ich einfach, da bin ich immer im Kalenderprogramm, ein Outlook oder ein Senderbord, kann ich eine Veranstaltung machen. Schreibe ich was, wo, wann, Beschreibung, hier noch einen Link oder so. Da gibt es einen Standard für ein Dateiformat, wo ich dann in meinem Kalenderprogramm sagen kann, ich speichere mir das als eine Datei. Und dann schicke ich an meinen Leuten per E-Mail eine E-Mail, die gehen an den jeweiligen Server, wo sich die Empfänger für entschieden haben, wo die E-Mail hingehen soll, wo sie halt ihren Account haben. Und dann ist eine Datei dran, können sie draufklicken, sich in ihren Kalenderprogramm laden und haben sie gleich in ihrem Computer, müssen danach noch nicht mal mehr eine Webseite aufrufen, um an diese Information ranzukommen. Und das ist einfach eine Sache, wie nutzen wir die Technik, die wir haben. Das hat jetzt wenige abgerundete Ecken auf dem Weg.
Man kann im Peer-to-Peer-Gedanken ja auch mal weiter spinnen. Ich finde das ja wichtig, dass man auch schaut, dass es ein ganz großer Set von vielen Anwendungsfeldern gibt. Und einer wäre zum Beispiel, wo man sagt, man begreift im Peer-to-Peer-Sinne eben auch Wireless Networking. Die Freifunk-Szene hat das jahrelang vorgemacht, zu sagen, wir versuchen uns untereinander zu vernetzen. Das wäre total super gewesen in Tunesien, in Ägypten und in einigen anderen Ländern in letzter Zeit. Wenn die auf ihren Handys ein Wireless Mesh drauf gehabt hätten, dann hätten die noch einen Uplink gebraucht und im Wesentlichen sich untereinander prima austauschen können. Also man kann das viel breiter noch denken. Und ich glaube auch, dass das gar nicht alles so abwegig ist. Wenn alle in zehn Jahren irgendwelche Android-Handys, Smartphones haben und da ist das halt per Default drin, dann müssen die halt den Revolutionary Mode einschalten.
Gut, wir werden gleich noch eine halbe Stunde darüber reden, ob man das vielleicht tatsächlich jetzt im GmbX mal hinkriegt oder nicht. Vorher gibt es das Frips Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und ich möchte euch doch noch eine kleine Musik präsentieren, denn ich habe heute auf Twitter herumgefragt, wer mal ein bisschen Musik fürs Chaosradio vorschlagen will. Und da ist unter anderem ein wirklich sehr schöner Track bei rumgekommen, Creative Commons Musik auch, kann man sich runterladen, einfach so der 8-Bit-Sound mit einem wirklichen Klassiker verbindet. Ich verrate jetzt erst mal nicht, was es ist, aber ich bin mir.
Dann ist Fritz Info und danach geht's hier weiter.
14 Informationen zum Datenverkehr.
Wegen des Kabelbrandes am Ostkreuz waren nicht nur Funknetze, sondern auch einzelne Rechenzentren in Berlin zeitweilig nicht erreichbar. So fielen nicht nur Internetseiten der Deutschen Bahn, sondern etwa auch der Grünen Partei aus. Infrastruktur der Piratenpartei lahmgelegt. Letzte Woche baten französische Behörden um grenzüberschreitende Ermittlungshilfe. Die deutsche Staatsanwaltschaft und die Polizei Offenbach schalteten deshalb vorübergehend die Internetpräsenz der Piratenpartei ab. Grund für den Schritt war ein freiliegender Bitterhaufen des französischen Energiekonzerns EDF in einer offenen Datenablage der Piraten. In Deauville wird Internetpolitik gemacht. Die Chefs der G8-Staaten drängen auf Maßnahmen, um Kinder vor Online-Straftätern zu schützen. Außerdem sollen Urheberrechtsverletzungen verhindert werden. Der französische Präsident Nicolas Sarkozy will Grundregeln fürs Internet. Bitte fahren Sie hier besonders vorsichtig.
Wir wünschen allen Datenreisenden eine angenehme Anbindung.
Vielen Dank Philipp Burger. Chaosradio heute im Blue Moon mit Markus Richter und natürlich wieder zahlreichen Gästen, nämlich Jena Jan Schallerböck und Wetterfrau Schallow und herzlich willkommen noch mal zurück. Ein lebendiger Aufmiss das hier und alle waren schon mal dran, nur der Wetterfrau Schallow nicht, der jetzt in zwei Sätzen erklärt, was ist eigentlich ein Dezentrale Soziales Netzwerk, das Ding, über das wir die ganze Zeit sprechen?
Das ist eine Alternative zu Facebook, bei der jeder selbst Teil des Netzes wird.
Und wie macht er das?
Indem er sich eine Software installieren kann, einen Server und selber sozusagen Teil des Facebooks wird und Accounts anlegt oder zumindest sich für einen anderen Anbieter entscheidet, nämlich einen von mehreren, ein soziales Netzwerk, das über eine Auswahl an Anbietern möglich macht.
Das ist ja bis jetzt noch ein relativ abstraktes Konzept, das gibt es noch nicht so wirklich. In einer Ausprägung kann man es versuchen. Diaspora versucht ja sozusagen eine Facebook Alternative, eine Dezentrale zu sein. Es gibt aber etwas, das schon so in die Richtung gegangen ist, nämlich Identica. Das ist ein Twitter-Klon. Also Twitter kennt ja alle 140 Zeichen, Freunde, also wie jemanden folgen, retweeten, replyen. Identica hatte genau diesen dezentralen Ansatz. Das ist sozusagen also ein Open Source. Das Open Source-Ding, da kann sich so ein eigener Server auch machen und es soll auch irgendwie alles untereinander funktionieren und mit Twitter. Und Jena, du beschäftigst dich ja mit diesem ganzen Ding auch so aus der User-Perspektive. Identica ist ein bisschen wie das Artefernsehen. Super Idee, aber keiner guckt's.
Ich hab jetzt gerade mal geschaut, was sagen die Leute jetzt irgendwie gerade aktuell zum Thema irgendwie Twitter versus Identica. Und Identica ist ja schon seit 2008 draußen. Also die haben das gestartet, die haben sich das Twitter angeguckt und Twitter ist ja auch mal gestartet. Also das heißt, kann man immer noch sagen, Anlaufschwierigkeiten hat jeder. Die Frage ist natürlich immer, warum benutzen die Leute das? Also Twitter hätte auch erst dann wirklich funktioniert, als nicht nur die privaten Kommunikationen, die privaten Konversationen zwischen einzelnen Menschen dort waren, sondern als man gemerkt hat, hey, ich kann Wolken von Begriffen mir anschauen. Ich kann sozusagen sehen, in der Real-Time, also in der Echtzeit kann ich mir anschauen, was denken die Leute eigentlich da draußen, was schreiben sie? Und in dieser kann somit eigentlich das machen, was die Meinungsforschungsinstitute vor, in den letzten 50 Jahren vor Wahlen immer gemacht haben. Die haben Leute angerufen und gefragt, was denken sie jetzt eigentlich zur CDU? Das kann ich heute ja irgendwie direkt jederzeit, jeden Tag mir bei Twitter anschauen. Und das ist der Mehrwert, den ich brauche. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich einen alternativen Software habe, die eigentlich dieselbe Funktionalität bietet, aber nicht genug Leute, ist die Frage, warum dorthin gehen? Was hab ich dort, wenn ich dort diese Menge nicht mehr hab und die Qualität auch nicht? Also wenn ich beispielsweise auf Identica eine Gruppe von Atomwissenschaftlern hätte, die sich zu Themen um Fukushima herum unterhalten würde und da debattieren würde, super, großartig, dann wäre das etwas, warum Leute sich tatsächlich damit auseinandersetzen. Also Content is King. Das war schon immer im Internet der Fall. Das bleibt hier auch natürlich in diesem System der Fall. Wenn ich immer nur Leute habe bei Identica, die sagen Hallo, ich bin jetzt auch da, sprecht mit mir, dann ist halt die Timeline nicht ganz so spannend, wie wenn Leute sich gerade irgendwie Fußball angucken und sagen Tor, juhu, endlich.
Ich glaube, dass die da mehr Aufmerksamkeit auf Datenschutz, unabhängig jetzt, wie es realisiert ist, in der Qualität nur gut tun kann. Also man hat nicht so den Effekt, wenn jetzt die Piraten sich alle intern irgendwie über was aufregen, als jetzt bei Nutzergruppe genommen, die jetzt auf Twitter sehr präsent ist, weil es einfach eine technikaffinierte Zielgruppe ist, dann geht halt das Schlagwort nicht sofort ganz hoch, nur weil es so sozusagen überproportional großer Anteil an Nutzer aus dieser Gruppe gibt, wenn die halt sozusagen ein bisschen verdeckter sozusagen ihre Kommunikation machen. Und das wäre ja sozusagen Seiteneffekt, der durch ein Dezentrale Soziales Netzwerk auch auftreten würde. Ich überlege mir, in welchem Kontext poste ich meine Meinung oder meine Nachrichten. Und wenn das halt jetzt irgendwie nicht öffentlich ist, kann ich ja sagen, das sind Dinge, da stehe ich öffentlich zu, die veröffentliche ich in meinen Profilen und die können über alle Knotenpunkte hinweg transferiert werden und man kann von jedem Punkt aus gucken, was du sozusagen gerade wirklich öffentlich gemacht.
Warte mal, ich bin gerade ein bisschen verwirrt. Hatt ich nicht eigentlich die Frage gestellt, warum Identika nicht funktioniert? Da gerade ein ganzes Stück wieder weg davon. Das ist aber genau die spannende Frage, die ich wissen möchte. Weil also noch mal meine kleine Privatsprivatschalistik, wer von euch findet aus Datenschutzgründen oder das Datenschutzperspektive Identika besser als Twitter? Handt ihn mal bitte ein, zwei, drei. So alle sind dafür. Das heißt, es scheint so eine Art Konsens zu sein, Identika ist schon eine coole Idee. Wenn jetzt einfach alle Leute, die Ahnung haben, dahin gegangen wären und gesagt hätten so, Twitter, Mittelfinger hoch, das klappt einfach nicht mehr, dann wäre das ja möglicherweise passiert. Aber es war halt so, die Leute sind zu bequem und gehen da nicht hin. Also woran scheitert das?
Weil es nicht unbedingt immer darum geht, was die Leute machen, die Ahnung haben oder die auch nicht unbedingt immer ihre Ahnung folgen. Es ist ein bisschen die Frage nach dem How do you get them to drink your Kool Aid? Wie es der Dave Recordin, der hinter OpenID steht, mal gesagt hat, mittlerweile arbeitet er bei Facebook. Und die Frage ist salopp übersetzt, wie kriegst du es hin, dass sie deine Brause trinken? Das heißt, wie kriegst du den Effekt hin? Und das sind momentan irre soziale und technische Innovationen, die permanent um uns herum stattfinden. Das ist eine wahnsinnig spannende Zeit eigentlich. Und da passieren dauernd neue Entdeckungen und neue Tools tun sich. Und dann ist das gerade hip und dann ist das. Und was es das nächste sein wird und was das nun spezifisch hip machen wird, das kann ich im Moment nicht sagen. Da gibt es, wie gesagt, zig Visionen und Ideen, wie das aussehen könnte. Und keiner hat bisher das Ding hip gemacht. Es gibt sozusagen nicht die Killer App dafür.
Genau.
Um zurück zu meiner Frage zu kommen, heißt es also, es kann gar nicht passieren, dass ein neuer Dienst gewinnt, wenn er einfach nur dasselbe macht, wie der alte Dienst, aber datenschutzfreundlich.
Also ich glaube auch, dass Identika deswegen nicht so durchgezündet hat, weil es sich eben nur als Alternative auf Twitter versteht. Und das ist natürlich total gut und super, da was zu haben. Das ist ja kein Kritikpunkt. Aber die Leute wollen ja, wie du auch sagst, nur einen Account haben. Und da ist ja schon Twitter und Facebook zu viel.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Da müsste man eigentlich gleich sagen, das ist ein Tool, das auch die Features von Facebook kann.
Alle dezentrale soziale Netzwerke, die ich heute gehört habe, hier werden auch nicht mehr erkennen als Facebook. Da wird auch keiner hingehen, aus genau dem selben Grund.
Ja, aber Facebook ist ja schon Twitter und mehr. Und wenn du halt hingehst und du machst nur eins für Twitter, dann kannst du auch nicht erwarten, dass das...
Nein, das ist klar das Identität. Was ich meine ist, es gibt diese Idee, die abstrakte Idee der dezentralen sozialen Netzwerke. Es gibt aber nichts, was ich bis jetzt, was ich heute hier gehört habe, was das besser könnte als Facebook, also für den normalen User. Von daher ist es doch eigentlich ein Kampf gegen Windmühlen.
Man muss ja sehen, wir haben jetzt gerade den Hund auf den Mund geschossen und schauen jetzt gerade irgendwie, wie lange der mit Sauerstoff überlebt. Also die Technologie ist überhaupt noch nicht so weit, dass wir wirklich verlässliche Zahlen und verlässliche User-Verhaltensrichtungen hatten. Wir hatten vorhin den Fall dieses einen ominösen Netzwerkgründers in Deutschland, der sozusagen Facebook kopiert hat und gesagt hat, ich bin jetzt irgendwie mit Lok in der King und kurze Zeit später ist das Ding jetzt eigentlich ja schon leer, weil keiner will es benutzen. Warum auch? Im Prinzip machen wir diese Erfahrungen gerade täglich neu. Und es ist der Unterschied zwischen Facebook und Twitter ist ja ein ganz, ganz, ganz großer. Bei Facebook kommuniziere ich mit den Leuten, die in meinem sozialen Mikrokosmos sind. Bei Twitter kommuniziere ich mit allen Leuten, die ich noch nie kenne, die ich noch nie gehört habe und mit denen ich noch nie irgendwas zu tun hatte, solange es um ein konkretes Thema geht. Also wenn ich einen Hashtag benutze und Leute, die zu diesem Hashtag etwas sagen, wenn ich mit denen schon mal kommuniziert habe, super. Wenn sie neu dazukommen und sozusagen auf diesen Hashtag in meine Timeline plötzlich aufpoppen, ist das auch super. Das sind ganz andere Kommunikationsmodelle. Deswegen gibt es auch die beiden Netze. Deswegen ist es auch nicht so, dass die Leute sagen, ich mache jetzt nur noch Facebook und ich mache nur noch Twitter. So Identica hat halt in dem Moment nur eine Kopie von Twitter angeboten, die dann auch noch in diversen Sachen begrenzt war. Identica ist vielleicht super für Unternehmen, ist vielleicht super für Mikrogruppen. Wenn man sich darüber unterhält, ob man heute Abend wassergefüllte Luftballons auf eine VIP-Party an der Oberbaumbrücke schmeißen will, dann ist das vielleicht besser, einen geschlossenen Dienst zu nutzen als Twitter. Also aus nachvollziehbaren Erwägungen. Aber für einzelne Fälle ist das vielleicht auch tatsächlich die bessere Lösung. Es wird aber nie diese Masse erreichen, solange es nicht einen USB hat. Also nicht einen Grund, den es besser, schneller und...
Genau, und was kann dieser Grund sozusagen, was kann Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerke realistisch vorstellbar für einen Unique Selling Point haben gegenüber Facebook?
Datenschutz und Ausbeisicherheit.
Genau, das ist kein Argument. Ganz ehrlich, für die große Masseleute ist es kein Argument, weil dann wäre Identica vor Twitter.
Ich gebe dir da völlig recht und ich glaube, man kann es schlicht nicht sagen. Das Netz ist voller emergenter Effekte. Es passiert plötzlich irgendwas, das niemand vorher hätte prognostizieren können. Teilweise sind es totale Zufälle und dann ist mal wieder jemand multimilliardär in USA geworden. Und teilweise sind es so Geschichten. Das fand ich ein tolles Beispiel irgendwie, wo du sagst, irgendwie die japanischen Nuklearwissenschaftler. Und plötzlich entwickelt sich da ein Netzwerkeffekt und BOOM! Ist dann irgend ein Ding ganz groß. Das ist vielleicht nicht Diaspora, sondern ein ganz anderes Ding, werden wir sehen. Aber das, was das Incentive ist, das ist ja nicht nur Datenschutz, sondern das ist ja auch eine ganz andere Netzwerkstruktur im Grunde, eine andere Architektur, die schafft andere Möglichkeiten. Und bisher haben sich immer die Architekturen durchgesetzt, die eine höhere Durchlässigkeit haben, weil die Anzahl der Möglichkeiten größer ist.
Was genau meinst du durchlässigkeit?
Das ist, kommen wir zurück zum Beispiel E-Mail. Da ist es ganz klar, das ist nicht in so einem geschlossenen System geblieben, sondern das ist irgendwann da rausgegangen, weil es einfach ein Plus an Möglichkeiten war, wenn du in einem Alternativsystem auch agieren kannst. Dann kann sich Konkurrenz rausbilden. Das sind ganz triviale Geschichten, ja. Also sonst hättest du überhaupt nicht diese Steigerung der Qualität von Web Interfaces bei E-Mail, also in den letzten Jahren erlebt, wenn das immer nur CompuSurf gewesen wäre zum Beispiel.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin skeptisch, ich halte es für eine gute Idee. Ich bin aber tatsächlich skeptisch, ob meine Mutter in irgendwie absehbarer Zeit Diaspora benutzt wird oder irgendwas, was danach oder sich ein Steck an ihre Steckdose steckt.
Aber machen wir das doch genau andersrum. Sagen wir doch mal jetzt ganz konkret, wie schaffen wir es, deine Mutter in dem Moment...
Alter, da hast du was zu meiner Mutter gesagt.
Deine Mutter hat ein Diaspora-Account. Wie schaffen wir es tatsächlich in kurzen, im kleinen Bereich solche Nutzung zu forcieren? Wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise einen Fritz-Diaspora-Note hätten, dann hätten sämtliche Hörer dieser Sendung...
Dann hätten wir ein Problem mit dem Rundfunkstaatsänderungsvertrag, weil wir natürlich keine soziale Netzwerke betreiben dürfen.
Aber gut, so wie es früher war, da hat man sich am Marktplatz getroffen. Das war sozusagen die Abbildung der sozialen Netze. Dann gab es irgendwann Fidunet. Das waren sozusagen schwarze Bretter noch per Telefonleitung. Da hat man sich dann mit dem Modem eingewählt und haben sich auch soziale Strukturen etabliert, die dann wiederum den Übergang ins Internet überdauert haben. Die sind dann jetzt inzwischen in den Newsgroups zu finden und schreiben sich Beleidigungen auf einem anderen Protokoll. Die Beleidigungen sind aber dieselben geblieben.
Also diese Attraktivität, dann muss ich denken, wahrscheinlich wird dann das nächste Facebook fortscheinern.
Das Fido-Net war ja schon auf dem Weg dahin, wo das Internet heute steht, ein solcher Zustand, wo halt der Haus-Nerd um die Ecke sozusagen, also da hat einer so ein schwarzes Brett betrieben und andere haben sich darauf eingewählt. Das war schon so eine kleine physisch geschlossene Benutzergruppe, die wiederum an ein Netzwerk angeschlossen war, weil sich eben diese schwarzen Bretter untereinander austauschten und damit auch protokollartig Informationen von dann wieder weiteren Brettern weitergegeben haben.
Aber gleichzeitig ist es ja so, dass man anthropologisch zurückschaut und sieht, dass die Dinosaurier nicht überlebt haben. Und die Fidunet-Betreiber ja auch wirklich, ja die muss man suchen. Die findet man nicht mehr an jeder Ecke oder in jeder Kneipe. Es ist halt schon so, dass sich das nicht durchgesetzt.
Ja klar, aber heute gibt es ganzen Nerds noch mehr davon als damals, die irgendwo einen Server oder einen virtuellen Server im Rechenzentrum haben und da auch irgendwie nicht nur Webseiten abvergangen können.
Völlig richtig. Was war früher die Motivation Fidunet Server zu betreiben? Das war, man war einfach an dem wilden Westen. Man hatte einen fast schon rechtsfreien Raum geschaffen, der noch unreguliert war. Man war irgendwo, wo es noch, wo noch niemand jemals zuvor gewesen ist, zumindest in dieser Form und dieser wilde Westen ist eben weitergewandert. Heute ist es vielleicht das Dezentrale Soziale Netz und wenn man diese Motivation, dieses Gefühl, dass etwas Neues, etwas Besonderes schaffen, wieder vielleicht wiederbelebt, dann könnte es auch dazu führen, dass sich solche starken sozialen Gruppen bilden, die dieses wiederum weitertragen und dann kann es passieren, dass du auf dem nächsten Konzert dann auch sagst, hey, wann kann ich dich wiedersehen? Hast du einen Facebook-Account und sagst, nein, ich habe einen Diaspora-Account.
Ich bin, also das hört sich sehr schöner, aber ich bin jetzt sagen, in der hin skeptisch, weil diese Fido-Sachen, hast du ja gerade gesagt, dass du sagen kannst, die geschlossene Gesellschaft, das ist das coole Underdog geschlossene Zirkelmäßige. Und genau, das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren, mit dem sozialen Netzwerk, wie wir es heute kennen.
Im Gegenteil. Die Frage ist, es darf halt nicht abgeschlossen sein. Es gibt ja heute schon so Netze parallel zu Facebook, die durchaus das Geschlossene als Vorteil sehen. A Small World zum Beispiel. A Small World ist ein geschlossenes Netzwerk, zu dem kannst du dich nicht anmelden. Zu dem musst du eingeladen werden. Und du musst also nicht einfach nur von irgendjemandem eingeladen werden, der schon da ist, sondern von jemandem, der wirklich auch approved in weiter ist. Und in dem Moment, wo du dich nicht ordentlich verhältst, wirst du auch wieder rausgeschmissen. Also es ist sozusagen ein absolutes Underdog in dem Fall. Hat sich auf eine ganz spezielle Zielgruppe fokussiert, aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es eine Subkultur, die sich dort rausbildet und die sich deswegen weiter trägt, weil die Leute dort tatsächlich mit Mitglied sein wollen und eben mitdiskutieren wollen, mit kommunizieren wollen.
Im Grunde war diese Exklusivität einer der Unique Select Points von Facebook am Anfang. Dass die in Harvard gestartet sind, das war deren Trick, um die kritische Masse zu erreichen. Ich glaube, man kann da unheimlich viele neue Ideen entwickeln. Ich hab ihn jetzt auch nicht für diese Dinger. Insoweit gebe ich dir dann recht. Vielleicht wird er nicht passieren. Aber ich glaube, es eröffnet auf der Ebene drunter so viele andere Möglichkeiten. Sicher bin, da wird sich irgendwas entwickeln. Und da kann man endlos rumspinnen, um die Frage mit deiner Oma nochmals zu beantworten. Ach nee, das war deine Mutter. Man kann ja auch überlegen, das Dezentrale Soziale Netzwerk hängt im Bilderrahmen an der Wand. Ich stehe überhaupt nicht auf diesen blöden digitalen Bilderrahmen. Aber meine Mama steht da drauf. Und vielleicht ist das für die ein totales Usability-Feature, wenn sie sagen kann, okay, das, was ich da an der Wand sehe an Bildern, das ist das, was auch gleichzeitig auf meiner Wall nach außen auch gezeigt wird, an Bildern von in einem bestimmten Kreis, von der Hochzeit. Meines Sohnes oder ich weiß nicht was. Und wenn sie sagt so, ich hab keinen Bock mehr drauf, dann nehm ich das ab. Das kann ich auch alles sozusagen simulieren. Aber dass sozusagen, dass es wirklich stimmt, das ist schon ein Feature.
Also ich überlege gerade tatsächlich, ob das möglicherweise der Punkt sein könnte, wo ich dann zuschlagen würde, wenn man die Elternsehwanderer an der Wand sagt, ne Junge, wie geht's dir denn? Und dann sind sie auf Facebook, deine Frau, und du denkst, das will ich hier aber jetzt nicht so richtig erzählen. Und wenn du dann, tatsächlich könnte es möglicherweise ein Punkt sein, wenn man sagt, ok, pass mal auf, melde dich mal bitte da an. Wenn das dann sozusagen genauso leicht wie Facebook zu benutzen ist, dann macht das für die ja keinen Unterschied. Also für manche Leute, die die nutzen ja Facebook, sagen nur für eine ganz, ganz, ganz kleine, enge Gruppe von Leuten, dann sag ich so, pass auf, melde dich mal da an. Da kriegst du nämlich öfter mal ein Foto zu sehen, wie ich nachmittags ein Eis esse. Oder mit welcher Frau. Und das wäre dann möglicherweise tatsächlich ein Punkt, um so kleinere Gruppen dahin zu kriegen. Dann wäre noch die Frage, ob das dann skaliert hin zu, wie sind da alle unterwegs? Find ich spannend.
Also ich glaub auch, dass es ein schleichender Prozess sein wird und nicht den großen Knall geben wird, außer durch irgendwelche lustigen Zufälle, die die Geschichte vielleicht spielen wird. Sondern einfach wirklich dieses auf Empfehlung arbeitende. Ich mein, jeder braucht immer irgendwie mal einen Experten zum Thema Computer, der irgendwie einem da was einrichtet. Und da hört man auf eine Empfehlung. Und wenn die Nerds übereingekommen sind über eine Lösung, die sie sagen, das ist jetzt besser und jetzt haben auch Nerds Lust auf Social Networking, weil sie es halt irgendwie technisch irgendwie okay finden.
Der große Nerdrad ist zusammengegriffen und hat entschieden.
Genau. Dann wird sich das auch weiter rumsprechen und rumkommen. Und gerade in dem Land, in dem wir uns hier befinden, ist der Datenschutzer auch immer wieder so wichtig, dass man sich da nicht die großen Sorgen machen braucht.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt ein Nerd-Zertifikat für Diaspora.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal weitermachen.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall in einem Land, wo Zertifikate sehr wichtig sind. Aber auf jeden Fall, ich wollte nochmal die Verbindung, bevor wir hier zu Ende gesprochen haben, die Verbindung zu Second Life ziehen. Weil Second Life ist ja auch eigentlich sehr grandios gescheitert. Eigentlich kann man ja inzwischen schon so sagen, dass er jetzt auch...
Wird noch benutzt, höre ich total gerne zu Schulungszwecken. Also in einem kleinen Rahmen.
Sehr kleinen Rahmen.
Möglicherweise, ja.
Also ich weiß noch, vor drei oder vier Jahren hat Daimler damals also einen riesengroßen Betrag investiert, um die neue C-Klasse by Second Life auch so zu lancieren. Und das haben irgendwie andere Unternehmen auch getan. Die haben also ganz viel Geld in die Hand genommen, weil sie gesagt haben, das sind die wirklichen Meinungsträger. Das sind die Leute, die wir erreichen wollen. Und im Endeffekt bräuchte es ja auch bei Diaspora, wenn wir sagen, wir haben ein dezentrales Netzwerk, wir haben ein Netz, wo Leute tatsächlich auch vertrauensvoll miteinander kommunizieren. Trotzdem die Möglichkeit, Informationen zu lancieren. Vielleicht ist es ja nicht immer böse. Es muss ja auch nicht immer böse sein. Es kann ja auch tatsächlich eine wichtige Warnung vor dem EHC-Virus sein, die man eigentlich wirklich bekommen möchte.
Wie du meinst, es müsste so eine Art Schalter geben, der Nachrichten durchschlagen lässt aufs ganze Netzwerk?
Es müsste auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit geben, innerhalb von Gruppen oder Zwischengruppen, zwischen zusammengeschalteten subkulturellen Diaspora-Nodes, institutionalisiert zu kommunizieren. Das ist eben ein Unterschied, ob ich das jetzt einfach schreibe, ich gehe heute ins Kino, oder ob ich den aktuellen Kinoprogramm von meinem Lieblingskino haben möchte. Wenn das Kino das sozusagen anbietet, dann habe ich eine höhere Motivation, in diesem Netzwerk auch teilzunehmen. Also wenn es Radio sagt, benutzt alle Diaspora.
Wir hatten ja gerade noch einen Anrufer, der ein bisschen zu spät gefragt hat, warum Fritz Facebook benutzt. Das wäre nochmal eine interessante Diskussion gewesen, aber kurz vor 12 mit so einer Frage an das Ruf ist echt ein bisschen ungeschickt. Ich kann nur ganz kurz sagen, wir sind da, weil ihr da seid. Wenn ihr da nicht werdet, werden wir da auch nicht. Das ist sozusagen die ganz kurze Begründung. Aber das war ja nicht die Hauptsache jetzt hier. Von euch nochmal jetzt jeder einen Satz. Wann werden wir Diaspora benutzen?
Ich wollte noch kurz einen kleinen Ausblick nämlich machen, dass auch Punkte sind, die bewältigt werden müssen. Ganz schnell. Nämlich erstens brauchen wir alle ordentliches Internet zu Hause und da wird es am 8. Juni den IPv6 Testtag geben, wo alle neue IP-Adressen mal ausprobiert bekommen sollen. Erst wenn wir die haben, kann jeder wirklich zuverlässig zu Hause einen Server beschreiben. Und dann müssen natürlich noch die ganzen Techniker übereinkommen und den Schlachtplan machen, wie dieses Protokoll funktionieren soll. Und die werden sich auch nächste Woche treffen auf einer Konferenz, die der Jan organisiert. Vielleicht da noch mal kurz den Satz von dir.
Aber ganz kurz, sehr kurz. Das ist ganz schwer kurz zu beantworten, aber das ist das Ding, wovon ich vorhin erzählt habe. Zusammen mit dem W3C gibt es ein großes Treffen in Berlin.
Sag doch einfach, wie es heißt und wo die URL ist.
descent.org dcent.org Super.
Dann vielen Dank euch, für's hier gewesen sein, uns Dezentrale Netzwerke-isieren. Wollt ihr noch irgendeinen Account von euch verraten, wo man euch befreunden kann? Na, na, wer traut sich?
DerWetterfrosch auf Twitter.
ULD62datenschutzzentrum.de Mein Name kann sich eh keiner merken.
Alles klar. Dann bleibt mir nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.